[Music]
you guys I was going to come out and do
uh my jokes which
are the best and
um but something happened in my personal
life and uh I was going to kind of
switch it up Pete if you're cool with
that okay uh basically um my girlfriend
of five years uh who was supposed to be
here tonight at the taping uh she broke
up with me over the
telephone and yeah that's right and um
so what I was going to do is I was going
to read a transcript of our final
conversation if you guys are okay with
that and
okay um would you buy any chance would
you mind coming up the girl with the red
would you mind coming up and playing my
ex-girlfriend reading the part of my
ex-girlfriend would you be okay with
that do you mind just standing over
here thank you for helping me no problem
um what's your name Ally hey allly nice
to meet you nice to meet you okay
um you look very pretty tonight oh thank
you thank you you're welcome sometimes
you give someone a compliment they give
you one back not always guys it's not
it's not a guaranteed thing you look
very nice too oh you're pretty fun oh
okay do you mind could you just scooch
over a little bit yeah thank you um are
you here is that your boyfriend that
you're with it's my boyfriend oh
right um okay uh Ally so uh I'm Sarah
you are Sarah so what will happen is uh
you have the first line I'll just hold
the microphone over and then you just
say the first line um is there any way
she said it was she nice about it um
like sweet probably less questions but
um uh so she that's probably why she
broke up with you just saying okay yeah
this isn't going to be your Your Big
Break tonight
um no yeah no just read it you just you
can
just you can just read it okay all right
cool thank you
though I may just do my ACT
um no allly I got a good feeling about
this I'll hold the microphone over and
you have the first line in the in the
transcript I should say Ally is playing
Sarah guys and um I call her Sarah
completely out of respect because that's
what her parents called
her so Ally here we go just I'll just
hold the mic over and you have the first
line here we go I think we should break
up that was great was that was really
good I I forgot this is my fault I
forgot one thing when you break up with
someone people always like who broke up
with who grow up all right guys it
doesn't matter who broke up with who
it's just just be adults sorry Alie do
you mind from we'll do that from the top
are you ready here we go I think we
should break up that was
great this is me sorry I didn't hear
that last thing the phone cut
out but I think we should break up
how long have you been with your
boyfriend Ally um three years oh W okay
all right did you what did you do on
your first day did he have you on a TV
show or anything like that on your first
day no okay it's not a competition it's
not a
[Applause]
competition um oh Ally this is your
whole uh monog okay are you ready yeah
do you have any acting experience nope
okay try to step it up a bit
um here we go I'll just hold the mic
over and just you you'll be great here
we go this is so hard you're such a
great guy and I love that you still live
with your
parents um I can't believe I'm not going
to get a chance to make love to you
tonight that is something that I highly
recommend to any single woman or even to
someone in a
relationship thanks for improvising that
thing at the
end
this is
me sorry the phone cut out
again what was that last
part I was just saying that in a perfect
world every woman on the planet would
get a chance to experience the Forbidden
pleasure that only you can
provide true
that
all right
babe all right babe I wish you the best
I've already had the
best I'll Always Love You donkey
Hammer allly everybody please take a bow
allly that was
[Music]
great